thousand reality space
Beyonce kicks off her highly anticipated
Renaissance World Tour giving major
queen bee energy I'm proud of it the
Grammy winner opened her sold out show
on Wednesday in Stockholm with
Dangerously in Love rocking a silver
custom Alexander McQueen jumpsuit she
slayed in this korres metallic leotard a
colorful David coma asymmetric skirt
with futuristic boots bedazzled nude
catsuit by lueve a pearl embellished
balmond bodysuit and for the show's
finale she floated down to the stage in
a high shine silver cape and matching
gloves but it was this sci-fi be
Ensemble by mugler complete with a
yellow and black leotard paired with
knee-high black boots and metal antennas
that stole the show you know because
Beyonce is Queen B and US fans We're The
Beehive I just know that that my passion
and my love
is what motivates me be belted out Flaws
and All one plus one I'm going down and
I care before moving on to tracks from
her Renaissance album which she dropped
last July
all in all Beyonce performed 37 tracks
for nearly three hours with no opening
act in front of 46 000 fans including
her hubby Jay-Z and 11 year old daughter
Blue Ivy who were spotted in the
audience she's uh incredibly hard worker
super talented
um very inspiring it's her first solo
run on stage in seven years and with 57
scheduled performances get this Forbes
predicts Beyonce could earn nearly 2.1
billion for this tour yeah billion with
a bee
[Music]
[Laughter]
and we did the math for you that's 37
million dollars per show anything
Beyonce do is amazing nobody is
surprised when Beyonce slays and across
the pond Stars couldn't help but gush
over Beyonce's big night at the mother
Premiere in La Beyonce kicked off her
tour in Stockholm did you have a chance
to see any images I haven't seen it yet
but you know Beyonce's female on you
know my my daughter and my wife they're
like they better sit front like you know
I got that type of talk since Christmas
this ain't now this is premeditated the
minute Beyonce say she doing the tour
it's over it's like you better get them
seats ready
the European leg of Beyonce's World Tour
will make stops in Belgium the UK France
Spain the Netherlands Germany and Poland
before the North American leg of the
tour kicks off July 8th in Toronto
[Music]
thank you